[Music]
all right
hello hello everyone that's watching on
youtube and welcome to in-person
audience
um
i'm wj and talia you probably know that
already
um but okay so
today we're gonna be talking
about
a game between
igor lisse and jeffrey sean
and the class is titled prepare like a
pro so we're going to talk about
how jefferson actually prepared for this
game which i find really exciting and uh
this was actually discussed in a in a
magazine that i really liked in
beginning of 2020 this is a
uh a game from the 2019
world cup where jeffrey actually did a
really good job if i'm not mistaken
he got to like semi-finals
quarter-finals something like that
quarterfinals yeah and then um
yeah this is actually a game that i use
as like a base when i was uh setting up
my queen's camera acceptor repertoire i
would say that um
obviously you know following games
from players that are specialists in the
openings that you play
will help you have a more solid and
concrete repertoire so that's one advice
for when you're
preparing and trying to set up your
lines
um
and in my case i guess jeffrey is just
really good and the queen's camera
accepted so that's why that's why i
would follow a lot of his games and
actually he was here
in
st louis finishing up a tournament about
a week ago the spring classic
and
i believe in one of the rounds you may
have had a queen's camera accepted in
fact i think i actually put it in the
notation of this game so we might go
over that
a little bit
um
but okay without
further ado
uh we have
d4d5 knight f3 knight f6
c4 d takes c4 by the way just for some
background context so this is round one
of the two rounds
in the ko
match
for world cup so if you don't know how
it works they essentially play two games
and
they're trying to get
essentially one and a half
out of the two
game points that you can have
if not then um
i guess i would go into like a rapid
tie break
so usually like when you have the white
pieces you want to be
a little bit aggressive maybe get some
advantage out of the opening because you
only have two games to
win this match so you're really trying
hard to use your advantage
and lisa is actually like a very very
good theoretician i usually i used his
book when i was setting up my e45
repertoire
my berlin repertoire
so um
jeffrey actually had to like do some
serious preparation for this game and
um the article that i read and also the
person that prepared him for this game
or at least helped him prepare um is
george f and i wasn't aware of this uh
i wasn't aware of this before this
lecture but he's actually the current
grandmaster in residence so that's
that's just like a funny like a funny
little thing
um
what are the actual steps to setting up
a repertoire in alicia study i guess you
would rather like first of all stick to
one opening um
i wouldn't recommend just like
jumping from line to line because uh
then you're never going to like
internalize one variation completely
um i recommend uh if you have a player
that you like or a style that you like
uh go for openings in that direction or
openings that that chess player plays um
and with the
leeches study if you want you can kind
of
make sure that your lines are popular
and you can find games there that you
can use as like key examples
for the lines
that you're playing so for example this
game for me in the queen's camera
acceptor is like a key game that i want
to study because it's
exactly the variation that i play
um and i would usu and like i said at
the beginning i would follow jefferson
games because he is kind of like an
expert in this line so yeah
um so those are some ways in which you
can use the leeches steli
um
okay but e3
e6 bishop takes c4c5 castle so this is
like a mainline queen's gambit accepted
and here there's like a very smart uh
subtle
deviation so oftentimes you see a6 in
this position
it's it's more of um the main line and
it kind of leaves this knight more
flexible in some lines you can play with
b5 bishop b7 and knight d7 just so that
the knight is not in the way of the
bishop that is going to develop
but that also has some
some mild drawbacks like sometimes this
variations of taking here can be a
little bit annoying
however
knight to c6 was played right away
and this also worked as a nice surprise
because previously in the tournament
jeffrey had played with a6 so
sometimes you know especially at this
high level
when players can actually make really
in-depth preparation
um
repeating the opening
can be a little bit dangerous because
it's kind of like a way of letting your
opponent know
what you're going to do and they can
have like
not necessarily an advantage but they
can have like the comfort of
actually understanding the positions
that they're gonna get into because they
started it beforehand
um and with knight to c6 it's just like
a very light
change and it can lead to some surprises
for white
so knight to c3 is what was played in
the game there is this interesting line
with a3 um i actually faced it in a
tournament in january
and the idea is also
kind of like a waiting move from white
just like what are you going to do in
this position you don't you could
develop this bishop you don't
necessarily want to do so
um because then when white takes here on
c5 you're going to have to move it again
so it's going to be kind of like a
wasted tempo and a6 is the main line and
now after it takes takes takes bishop
takes with the help of the phone on a3
white can actually play b4
and next turn play bishop to b2 and then
they have like a really
quick development it doesn't lead to any
great advantage for white or anything
but it just leads to like some positions
where maybe white is a little bit more
comfortable in the same game and if
black doesn't know what they're doing
um
they can mess up strategically and white
can get
very comfortable
this knight can even go to d2 and b3 and
control this squares
and there we can go to c1
so yeah um like i said jeffrey actually
had um
a game in this variation in this
more recent tournament in saint louis so
i'm just gonna like really quickly
take a brief look at that so castle
knight bb2
um
bishop d7 you should be two and rook of
the eighth so white black is playing
very solidly
you usually would put the rooks on d8
and c8 sometimes you even take this rook
to c8
black doesn't have any immediate
weakness and overall the position is
very comfortable this bishop on d7
oftentimes you can even bring it back to
e8 and there is no problem in that
because if any possibilities of like a
trade happen you don't really mind it
like let's say maybe knight to b3 you
probably don't mind trading off the
rooks it's just going to be like a
regular solid equal end game
and
white is usually trying to
get something more than this so
black already kind of did their job in
the opening so
okay
but this is not what happened like i
said knight to c3 is removed from the
game and pawn to a6 d takes e5
and
here actually georgiev kind of goes in a
little bit of
depth on
how
maybe because white was surprised for
this new move order they decided to
not risk anything and just go into this
solid end game
however here it's going to be a little
bit more difficult for white to try and
get some
as we were saying right because it just
kind of
just
uh waters things down
into
a position without queens like i said it
can still be very dangerous
uh but there is not much advantage to
fight on for
compared to
like i'm just randomly gonna point out
one line
so there's this line with queen to e2
that is actually very um
threatening i guess if you don't know
how to play it b5 bishop to b3
uh rook to d1
oh sorry uh
did i play this right
no my bad my bad
so
uh queen two e2
a3 rook to g1 b5 takes quincy seven
bishop b3 this can be one line um in
fact actually i think um i
somehow i managed to sneak into a loren
chess 24 simul once upon a time and he
we played this line and he played bishop
b3 i played c4 bishop c2 and black
actually can get like this nice
uh
pawn structure here
but it also allows white to play e4 in
the future and control the center which
can lead to some like dynamic battles
so those are just some lines in case
someone is watching and like
um you don't necessarily want to get
into an end game right away with the
white pieces that's that's one option
but knight c3 a6 d takes e5
um
and
uh george f actually condemns this as
like
a
strategical mistake not necessarily
because of the position but just because
of the situation of the match right
where you only have white pieces one
time
um if you lose your chance here next
game jeffrey schoen is going to have
white pieces and he's going to push for
something more
right
so
this is obviously like a much more
serious scenario but maybe you can also
take these things into consideration
when you're preparing for your own games
or if you're playing close tournaments
or matches
okay but queen takes d1 rook takes d1
bishop takes c5 and knight to d2 this is
a little bit different to the end game
that i was showing earlier right because
it's this knight on f3 the one that is
going to d2 before the the knight hadn't
been developed just yet it was still in
b1 so you could actually play knight b1
to d2 and then knight to b3 here it's
this knight the one doing the regrouping
right
so um
the whole point is that the knight is
going to d2 it's gonna go to b3 next
turn and then there are gonna be ideas
of e4 bishop e3
and bring the rook to c1
uh bishop to d2 was another move but it
seems like after castle rook c1 bishop
d7
bishop b2 and bishop a7 just so i don't
know
knight jumps attacking this bishop here
on c5 the position seems to be quite
comfortable
and for example bonfires has played this
line as well if you want to follow
more games
but okay after bishop takes c5 knight to
d2 bishop to e7 was played and this
actually is not a very common move in
fact it was uh it's the only game in
this very in this variation with bishop
to e7 oftentimes you see castles right
away and then knight b3 bishop to a7
um
there is no real
um
danger in this position like if
you move the bishop either way
and because some of the ideas are moving
the pawn to e4 you want to keep this
bishop in this diagonal so
but okay bishop to e7 this was still
preparation by jeffrey and his team
bishop to e2
castle
knight to b3 and now this really
interesting move pawn to e5
we have talked about how white
is the one that may want to get some
space with pawn to e4 but black is also
saying okay i want i want space too i
want to play e5 and i'm going to develop
this bishop
um
in the in the long diagonal rather than
making a fan shadow
right
uh white is trying to get some advantage
but there really isn't uh
that much in this position
uh b5 is one idea but when you play b5
you always have to take into
consideration the possibility that this
could be weak in the future
so after something like pawn to e4
bishop b7
bishop to f4
rook t1 f3
the bishop it's not really attacking
much because of the solid structure
and maybe there can be some ideas of a4
later it's kind of um
kind of almost
resembles like a sicilian queenside
pawn structure
but obviously the opening is very very
different
it's still possible but playing with e5
just leads to
simpler positions
you don't necessarily want to
make weaknesses for yourself or may or
may hooks in the position right that
your opponent can later use to attack
or
create weaknesses right and holes in the
position
so that's why pawn to e5 was played
bishop to
f3
and bishop to e6
and now bishop takes c6 was played what
do you guys think about this this move
or this idea to trade off the bishop for
the night
and like what are what why do you think
white may have played it or why do you
think it was a bad idea
and just feel free to say whatever
that's true so obviously black is going
to take and
now the pawns are separated
right
so that is one thing
any other comments anyone wants to make
so someone is saying that they don't
understand it at all and that it looks
terrible
okay and that bishop takes c6 and the
white's knights are terrible
well i mean
obviously the ideas of the knight is
going to jump to a5 right and it's going
to put some pressure on this pawn
but
is there any other um
thing that maybe you guys want to point
out about this train
that is actually quite important
uh
what do you mean
okay
yeah the pawn is still on asic so the
rook doesn't have the the freeway
um
yeah
so there is one other really
big
detail
and obviously jeffrey is not just going
to allow his phone structure to get
damaged right there is something that he
gets back from this
why could that be
i guess this is kind of more of diving
to the topic of like
when trades are good or how to make
trades in certain positions
and which pieces are better than which
mayo what could be the what could be the
thing that jeffrey gets back from this
from the strain
okay so someone in the chat is saying um
white has many pawns on dark squares
and
though that's likely to change but yeah
the main thing is the two bishops right
then now white gets the pair of bishops
um oftentimes it is said that a pair of
bishops can compensate for a damaged
constructor just because they can
control so much together
so maybe you can keep that in mind for
when you're playing um
especially in end games the two bishops
can be very damaging
just because of
how how much they can control with the
free space that they have yeah so bishop
pair
would be the reason why also it seems
like this bishop right here doesn't have
that many
good squares to go to so
we can also take that as a
as a problem um
and
yeah
essentially
this just
um
lets black have a comfortable
comfortable position and
it almost seems like black is trying to
like white is trying to push for some
sort of
advantage out of the opening or like
they're still trying to hang on to like
that idea that
white is automatically having a little
bit of an edge
at the starting position and they're
trying to find for to fight for some
weakness or something to compensate for
the fact that black had just gotten
no problems out of the opening uh but
this only makes things worse
uh because it is black now who has
some chances so yeah
um yeah and the and the board is a
little bit it's kind of open like there
could be more upon trades but there is
this open file that could be
an issue and overall the black pieces
are all fine and
for example this root controls an open
file but there is no way that they can
break in
right so knight to a5 was played right
after and then rook fc8
um
look fc8 and then you're gonna put this
rook on the b file that's why you picked
this rook
bishop to d2 rook b8 pawn to b3 and now
bishop to a3
bishop to a3 preventing the other rook
from getting to the key square
bishop to
and now there's this really nice move
um that was played with the intention of
getting rid of the most active piece of
black the white house in this position
so
what is
what is the most active piece that white
has and how can we like kick it away
uh i would say that the knight on c3
it's obviously developed but it doesn't
it's not quite doing anything right now
because most of the jumps are controlled
not all of them there's a4 but most of
the jumps are controlled
so
maybe the other night
maybe the night on a5 just because it
attacks here as well
so
there is just one simple move that we
can do to
make this knight go away
yeah bishop to b4
and
um
i mean here you can see like how a
grandmaster thinks right like
uh they already have a comfortable
position but they also want to make sure
that they're taking away all of the
good pieces that white has that the
opponent has right
so uh knight to c4 was played the knight
retreated another possibility would have
been knight to a4 maybe
um because this bishop
would be defending indirectly the the
knight on a5
but right now uh
there is bishop takes
takes
and rook to b5
and it never allows a knight to reach c5
that's a very key thing you don't want
to just
give the knights the outpost
so
rook to b5 controlling the square also
attacking on a5 once again and after
knight to c4 takes takes
rook a5
and the position is a little bit better
for black after knight c3 rook a3
um if you you could argue for rook b4
but i think there might be knight c5 so
yeah
and if takes
it takes i think
actually i'm not sure if this works
but still you just don't want the knight
get into c5
um okay
um so there there are actually some
questions of like why play bishop to a3
and then bishop to b4 i think it's the
white is actually
sorry black is actually like comfortable
enough that they can
afford to
make this tempos it's not like the
bishop on e1 is any better than it was
on d2 like it's not actually
improvement and um
it just kind of allows for more control
in this endgame
yeah bishop to e1 bishop to b4
and um after this knight to c4 was
played
and
we can actually play bishop take c4 and
b take c4
we are giving away our bishop pair but
at the same time we have a lot of
initiative in this position
the fact that the pawn on c4 is weak as
well
uh it's gonna be quite important
and also we have control of the b file
and
overall
it's it's nothing crazy it's only just
very small
edges
but it's gonna lead
black to have the to be the one having
the possibility to increase their
advantage rather than white
so
now we're gonna just follow in-game
principles into a f8
rkb1 king to e7
and the pawn on c6 even though it almost
seems like it should be weak because
it's lonely it does a really nice job at
controlling any possible jumps from the
knight on c3 right um especially with
the king on e7 when there might be some
knight d5 ideas it just does a really
good job at
controlling that
um
yeah
technically if you think about it i
think there could be this move rook
takes b4 but after rook takes knight d5
uh it doesn't really
have
much of an impact i think there's just
night takes bishop takes and takes so
yeah
doesn't quite work
soak into f1
uh someone is saying that
jeffrey might have lost some advantage i
wouldn't say so because and i could also
get very annoying
and
you'll see what happens in the game but
essentially
the
black position is going to be the one
improving and they technically have more
space if you think about it because of
the pawn on e5 versus the pawn on e3
it's just all very small advantages like
the bishop on b4 is better than the
bishop on e1
um the king is slightly better than the
one on f1 it's just like little little
things that are all going to a man up
so
pawn to a5 was played pawn to f3
knight to d7
um
where do you guys think this knight is
going on f6 he wasn't doing much right
so the knight is going to regroup to a
better square
it's
if you think about it
yeah
uh yeah b6 then i can go to b6 and put
pressure on this phone on c4 so they
have to do something about it
and it can also have ideas of jumping to
c5 because
when the knight gets to c5 there's
really no way to kick it out of there
right
um
yeah so
that is one idea and you can take this
into consideration sometimes for when
you don't know what to do in the
position because um one of the questions
actually was like how do you plan to
penetrate in the position
um
in general to improve you have to take
into consideration the pieces that are
not really doing anything in this case
it would be
the knight on f6 it doesn't really have
any squares to jump to
and you go look for a better square for
it and automatically you know you
consider knight d7 and the possibilities
of the knight going to c5 or
b6 right
so
well there's a saying that if you don't
know what to do just don't make the
position worse
but if you can you know obviously
improve your pieces right like here
um
so
knight to d7 and then king to e2 was
played simply allowing the knight to go
up
um
another move may have been knight to e4
trying to control the square here on
on
on c5
um but maybe what why didn't i like
about this is that there is this move
pawn to f5 right just kicking the knight
away gaining even more space in the
center
and after bishop h4 check just knight of
six
and take stakes
even though the pawns are double
um there's really
nothing that you can do about it because
it's
how you're gonna try and put pressure on
the double pawn simply bishop to f2 and
bishop to c5
and the position maybe has a little bit
of an edge for
for black
nothing too crazy just a little bit of
an edge
but that didn't happen so king to e2
and now knight to c5 was played
i believe knight b6 is also
playable
uh now that i think about it
why wouldn't you go knight b6
i think there might be some ideas of
i don't know i don't know exactly if
this works i think there might be some
ideas of like pawn to c5
and if bishop takes c5 knight to e4 i
feel like maybe this is the
the reason why and now this is hanging
and also the bishop is attacking here on
a5
you know sometimes it's it's better to
just like restrict your opponent's
position as much as you can right and
actually go for
for
i i guess like after the problem because
the pawn on c5 the phone on c4 is very
annoying
in general for white themselves just
because it's not an open file
it doesn't really allow them
any space
and
at least if the pawn was gone you could
try and double up the rooks on the c
file and put pressure on c6 right but it
seems like the pawn is just in the way
of everything
so
yeah
um yeah i mean
white has a black has definitely
equalized but not only that they're the
ones that have chances in this position
um someone is saying that if knight b6
that i have knight b6 c5
then knight to d7
i guess you could go knight to e4 now
and i mean we're kind of offering
this exchange
uh you cannot play bishop take c5 do you
guys see why
does anyone want to maybe suggest a move
here for white
maybe checks captures and threats
the bishop has the defender right so
maybe we can
if we get rid of that defender we can
take the bishop
so some people in the
yeah
right so after this
it will be checked so the king has to do
something about it and then takes and
then knight takes c5
and
i would say like 90 of the time we're
good with the idea of having two pieces
for a rook right
um
it just covers more ground and
two pieces better than one
so
yeah
um
this would have been like a tactical
idea it all comes with checks so it's
all good
so the bishop cannot take it um if
bishop takes simply rook takes e1 and
you don't have enough attackers here on
c5
and
[Music]
if you take with the knight then
something similar can happen white would
get rid of the
defender of the knight this bishop
making a pen and after it takes take so
it seems like white is uh black is never
on time to take the c pawn
oh and if um
and if bishop takes e1 let's say like
rook takes e1
um f5 you might run into some problems
after knight d6 and this double attack
so yeah
but okay so knight to c5 is what was
played in the game
and
if you take like a brief look at it like
i'm going to flip the boards real quick
it almost looks hard to make moves as
white if you think about it
um
maybe something that comes to you that
could like fight for some space is e4
but this actually
creates more problems than
any other thing because now there are
ideas of knight to e6 right and you just
gave me the really important d4 square
my knight is going there next right
and the difference
uh it's like an ironic difference it's
the fact that the pawn on c4 is way too
advanced and it will never control d4
and the pawn on c6 is just perfect
controlling any jumps from the knight
right
um
yeah
so yeah
someone is saying that they didn't
really understand how good black's
position was until i flipped the board
and yeah i mean if you if you think
about it it's it's a little bit hard to
make moves you can give a check but it
doesn't amount to anything just f6 and
now this is hanging
it's really hard to make moves and it's
only been 24 moves and your wide pieces
so you were supposed to be comfortable
from the opening
um
but yeah
another white position it's just
um difficult to play
and rook d to c1
king to e6
just centralizing even more
rook to c2
rook to d8 and rook to a1
this is a really weird looking move
right um
what georgiov mentioned is that um
that listing my
lissy white pieces uh might be
frustrated by the way that this position
went and maybe they didn't want to offer
too many trades because for example rook
to d1 is an option right and we always
talk about how when you have less space
or the position is uncomfortable
you want to trade pieces right
one problem though is that after rook
takes d1
king takes d1
um f5 q2 g5
nothing
too major there is no material advantage
it's just
positional advantage right like black
has so much space the knight on c5 has a
really strong outpost doesn't even allow
the king to go up
the pawn on c4 is weak this bishop on e1
is is
not doing much the rook is awkwardly
placed on c2
it has to defend ideas of like
infiltration in the future
and overall all of the all of the black
pieces are in good spots and all of the
white pieces are kind of struggling
right
obviously
this is not comfortable but it it does
like just
by eye test right it looks a lot better
than making a move like rook 2a1 right
like this is uh there is no way that you
can make a move like rook 2a1 and think
that everything will be okay
right
it kind of has the idea of pushing a3
and at least you know asking the bishop
what it wants to do like trying to
provoke something
um
but it doesn't quite
it doesn't quite
work so
jeffrey just went pawn to f5
if a3
i guess here we can think of it as like
every time that you move a pawn you're
going to leave some weakness behind so
after pawn to a3 what is the weakness
that was left behind
uh yeah so b3 is the weak square i think
knight b3 is still possible and if you
play for example rook to b1
um something like takes and then you may
actually run into some problems because
the rooks are on the same file and after
something like bishop takes
do you have any like potential discovery
idea
there is one spot where you can move the
knight and it can be checked and then
the king has to do something
um like to deal with this check and in
the meantime we can use the rook to take
on b1
yeah so you can go knight to d4 and then
after it takes rook takes b1 you're not
really worried about giving up the
knight because you got the rook right so
you're just an exchange hop in this
position
so yeah um if if white is not careful
they can fall into some tactical tricks
this it's kind of bound to happen when
um
like one side is pressing for an
advantage for so long it just becomes
almost
um practically impossible to to defend
all of the threads
um and if something like rook two a two
just not really going there you can
always play something like takes takes
a4
and
the knight has a great job at like
controlling most of the squares that
rook can go to right the bishop doesn't
have any targets the pawn on e5 is
always protected by the
by the um
by the king
and
overall it is just black the one that
has the space and
the more comfortable position so
yeah
you can play something like bishop to b4
but after c5 bishop back like it's it's
only
black who can improve right
once again if i flip the boards it's
probably going to become really
difficult to find moves for white
so yeah
all right
so that a3 was not actually
that great even bishop takes here right
away it was another possibility and then
a4
so um instead
rook to d1 was played why kind of
realized that there were no
no other options they just needed to
simplify somehow hope that they can hold
in the end game
but after rook takes d1 king takes d1
um
there is just
uh there are actually a lot of options
you can still play with the g5 that
we're seeing earlier
um
i don't know if rook 2d8 is as good it
probably is
but jeffrey decided to play with pawn to
e4
and the idea of pawn to e4 is that
you're going to obviously control even
more space you may even get the square
on on d3 right for the knight with
support from the pawn
and it doesn't really
it doesn't really work the same way as
how we were talking about a3
because
the square that the squares that get
left behind are d4 and f4 but how are
you going to use them like how are you
gonna
go there with your knight it's not so
easy let's say a knight to e2 if you
want there's always stakes takes
and rook b1 or something
so
it's just very difficult to play
so pawn to e4 f takes e4 f takes e4
king to e2 was played
and
now this move i don't really know how to
explain it he play rook to b7 i assume
he just realized that okay i can i can
do whatever i want with my position i
have time this is more of a static
advantage
so the thing about
this type of advantage compared to like
something that you may get out of the
opening
um is that
you can take your time and the advantage
is not really going to go away it's not
like initiative that
you have to use quickly and like make
some sacrifice open up the position
here you can actually take your time and
not much is going to change
the structure is pretty much fixed
so no pawn breaks are possible and
just little by little
black can increase their potential
someone is asking what move it is and
they're saying between move 35 and 40
but this is actually move 30. so
uh i i think it's just the illusion that
we traded off queens so early but it's
it's you know it's most 30 it's
relatively early in the game
so rook to b7
bishop to d2
rook to d7 going for the open file
knight to b1
trying to have some make changes
and um i i guess technically we could
play something like bishop takes but
that only improves this night
and
obviously the stream wasn't happening
when i was doing my previous lecture but
i was teaching latest night before this
class and we briefly had a like a like a
little talk on
how
how to do trades and um
obviously you know if you take here
that's completely fine but it's going to
improve this knight to a better square
so
um
might as well instead
do something like into e5 let's say and
this trade is a lot more beneficial for
for black because now the a file is open
and maybe you can use it as like a
target or you can
have some ideas of knight a4 knight c3
if this knight goes away
and overall the white position is just
gonna crumble apart
so be careful when you do trades
um
that could potentially
improve the pieces of the opponent you
don't really want to do that
and jeffrey is not just anybody he
understands this so he played knight to
d3
and yeah you could argue that black is
winning now
pawn to a3 was played
and now he did like a really brilliant
move
um
is going to absolutely take away any
any activity that white could ever hope
for so it's a tough move to see
so i'm going to give you guys some time
anyone feel free to suggest whatever
but
um
yeah so
it's it's kind of a tough move to see
but
it's just crazy how after this move
white is just gonna have so little
activity it's gonna just be absolutely
difficult to make moves
it's about time that we start getting to
the white side of the board right
but how
so you're saying c5 and having two
passers so i assume that after c5 takes
you want to take with the spawn the
problem is that you might also be giving
a password to
to white right like they can play
something like c5
and then b3 i assume like rook c4
and then it's not so clear anymore
you're accidentally giving too many
chances to white that they don't deserve
so
um maybe something along the same lines
but not quite with c5
do any of you guys have any suggestion i
mean
um
you can feel free to say whatever move
and we can discuss it
rook f7
yeah actually that's a that's the move
that was played rook two f7
nice it always feels nice right when you
guess a grandmaster move
um i remember uh
there was only like one
tournament not only one but there was
like one international tournament in
havana that i used to go to when i was a
kid to watch and
my mom tried to bribe me every time and
she said that i could have a piece of
gum every time i guess the gm move so
yeah it feels nice when you guess the
move
by by a grandmaster and um yeah rook
through f7 is the move that he played
and the idea is that after a takes b4
you have rook to f2 there is only one
place the king can go to which is d1
and then a takes b4 and once again i
don't think i need to flip the board i'm
just going to do it to show you but what
do you do what do you do as white like
the knight is completely stuck the pawn
on b4 controls both
both squares
the bishop doesn't have any good square
to go to
um
and
you know the king can't move either the
rook
i guess it could go to a2
but there are ideas of either this or
pawn to b3 everything is just crumbling
and yeah everything is just kind of
falling apart so
bishop to c1 was played
um
just for accuracy if you play like rook
a2 i still have b3
uh you have to be careful of where you
go to
because
like rook a6 for example there's rook f1
came
and this is no longer being protected so
you can take it
um
if bishop takes b4 and you're just
trying to like at least
give up the material again so that you
can have some sort of activity there's
just root 2 f1
uh king d2
and takes
and this is hanging this is hanging
and
black also has control of the seventh
rank as well and they're going to take
the pawns later on
after like group b2 c5
so
um
what happened in the game was it takes
before bishop c1
hoping that at least the rooks get
traded off but simply rook to f1
king to d2 and
after one repetition
just b3
and here white pieces resign because
what do you do um
the rook only has one square it can't go
here because of the oops because of the
night
in fact i'm going to show you take six
the problem is this falls afterwards
if it goes to
if it goes to c3
then
you can probably win with like a
thousand different moves but it seems
like the easiest one is b2
um you have to do something about the
bishop and after bishop takes you could
take you can also play rook takes um
b1 you can also play rook two f2
king down and then knight takes b2 or
even rook takes b2
and then
technically material is the same
technically material is the same but the
big difference is just how the pieces
are placed right this skin is much
better than the skin
the knight on a3 has no future uh the
rugan c3 is very awkward and it isn't
attacking anything
the knight on d3 is a monster and the
rook on b2 is just going to collect all
of the pawns on the king side and then
you can march
with their own pawns so
yeah
after a night after
i think after uh yeah after b3 is when
white pieces resign
and jeffrey actually won with the black
pieces and he went on to win this match
so
uh
obviously this opening choice and
preparation was very successful
and yeah so that's all there is to the
game
so just to recap i guess some key points
is
uh the preparation that he did was
really good he changed
a little bit the
line that he's comfortable with he just
didn't make it so that it was easier so
it was easy for the opponents to prepare
he changed a few little things
white wasn't able to get anything out of
the opening and that probably was uh
frustrating because why this
you know there's like
the
stereotype that white is supposed to get
something
out of the opening
uh the end game uh
jeffrey just played better and had more
accurate ideas and this bishop takes c6
actually was
a damaging choice
for white because
it allowed black to have the bishop pair
the open file and we all know that
that's how
he won later so
yeah
and of course another very important
thing is that black also never allowed
white to get back any chances or any
advantage or any counter play
uh which is always nice to do in the
games because um
just makes it even harder for your
opponent to defend even if the position
is not like practically winning
so yeah um any
questions
that's fine if that or not
but yeah i hope that at least
you guys like this game and like i said
jeffrey played in
the spring classic uh i've talked
briefly about it in
some other lectures but the spring
classic finished a week ago here
and he was playing in it i don't think
he did as great as he thought he would
but still he had some really nice games
and he still plays this line which is
nice for me because i get to watch it
and learn from it um
yeah i mean i wish i could play like
this i played this line in january and
then i accidentally um spent too much
time and i was holding on for most of
the game but then like move 60 i made
like a blunder and everything went to
trash so i guess i have to keep studying
it
yeah um
but okay so yeah i guess i'll
uh that will be all for today
and
yeah that was a lecture
all right um
i don't know what you want me to do with
this camera just say hi okay bye
all right
[Music]
you